performance in boys town i'm very happy  congratulations  thank you cecedri  i uh i don't  bother flanagan  congratulations betty saying to you sven  thank you  it is a personal pleasure and honor  to present this award  to you mr harry m warner mr roosevelt it  has been a great pleasure  special awards for two juvenile players  who have set a high standard of ability  and achievement ms deanna durbin  thank you very much mr bergen  you too charlie ah sorry  and now for the boy who has given the  most to the screen in the past year i  want to thank you for this great honor  charlie huh you're not the boy oh i i  feel that i don't deserve what you're  not the boy  well i've been framed who is it well  it's mickey rooney nicky roney yes never  heard of him